when Donald Trump announced his
candidacy the media reacted with horror
to this statement when Mexico sends its
people they're not sending their best
they're sending people that have lots of
problems and they're bringing those
problems with us they're bringing drugs
they're bringing crime they're rapists
and some I assume are good people
while many some at least quibbled with
the formulation the president made there
they knew what he basically meant maybe
shouldn't have singled out Mexico people
are coming from a lot of places doing us
harm and I'll tell you tonight there is
continuous and sad evidence to
substantiate his claims of the
underlying crimes every day in this
country there are fresh American
tragedies to report on American citizens
brutalized abused murdered by illegal
aliens yet most of these stories are
buried at the back of the local metro
sections in your local papers and most
of them are never heard on national news
broadcasts well the media they're too
busy doing what they're capturing every
utterance of a few specific porn stars
so tonight we're going to report on a
handful of these American tragedies in
San Diego a Mexican illegal alien
Constantino Banda Acosta
after a night of drinking was charged
with running a stop sign and slamming
into a family's vehicle a little boy in
the back seat of the vehicle suffered
serious head trauma and now has
cognitive issues Acosta fled the scene
in addition to being an illegal alien
Acosta had been deported 17 times yes 17
last week a judge declared a mistrial in
his case because they couldn't establish
if it was he or the illegal alien in the
car with him who was actually behind the
wheel at the time of the crash
thankfully he was turned over to federal
custody following the mistrial but given
California sanctuary state laws I expect
he's going to find his way back into the
goal
State and then this in Fairhope Alabama
on Sunday
a twice deported alien Jose Luis Alonso
de Leon is accused of crashing his truck
into a local woman who was on her bike
and they killed her Alonso de Leon was
also drunk he too fled the scene at the
crash
authorities later found him in
possession of a stolen gun and believe
he's used seven aliases in the past so
they're now investigating his criminal
history a law enforcement official and
the sister of the victim will join us in
just a few moments
and last Friday in the suburbs of New
Orleans at 2:00 in the afternoon
this charmer sauntered into a Walmart
his name is Billy yo booty Ayer Herrera
he allegedly approached a mother and her
two-year-old child with a machete he
told the mother if she didn't listen to
his instructions she and her child would
die he then tried to kidnap the infant
the mother resisted and hid with her
baby behind the deli counter Budhia
herrera then ran off and attempted to
abduct another child from a chopping
shopping cart Walmart employees and an
off-duty officer ended up tackling him
he's charged with kidnapping aggravated
assault and an immigration detainer has
been placed on him look I didn't even
have time to report on the other crimes
that are percolated out there just in
the last few days Salvadoran illegal
immigrant travel a traveling pastor no
less charged just last week with
enticing a 14 year old girl in Virginia
to record sexually explicit videos of
herself investigators believe this freak
may have victimized many others or the
Guatemalan twice deported illegal who
allegedly raped a teenage girl he posted
bail in February and escaped before ice
could detain him or the illegal in
Dallas who's charged with smothering a
senior citizen and may be according to
authorities a serial killer this own
scratches the surface of crime committed
on a daily basis by those who should
have never been in this country in the
first place every life lost every child
harmed every woman abused our victims of
not only the criminals who committed
those crimes but also of the government
that allowed criminals to enter this
country in the first place and frankly
I'm sick of this argument I don't really
care what percentage of illegals in the
United States commit crimes and what
percentage doesn't even one American
life lost at the hands of an illegal
it's too much it is unacceptable and
contrary to what the media tell us those
who have floated our laws and the
families they've dragged with them are
criminals
the people who cross this country's
border are criminals they are not
victims our policymakers they're
supposed to represent us address our
needs not cater those of illegal
immigrants Donald Trump understands this
and he's right to step up enforcement
across the board the American workers
American taxpayers I think are really
tired of feeling like second-class
citizens in their own country like
they're the interlopers as illegal
immigrants brazenly demand rights and
legal benefits that dynamic is starting
to change because of President Trump we
Americans and all you hard-working legal
immigrants out there must demand that
lawmakers stop protecting the
lawbreakers and start protecting us and
that's the angle